ALX Garland's anihilation might be the
prettiest end of the world movie you'll
ever see based on the novel of the same
name by Jeff Vandermeer the movie tells
the story of a group of scientists
venturing into a strange quarantine zone
called the shimmer inside they encounter
a surreal world that seems to be remix
in itself and everything in it the film
juggles some heavy themes and has a lot
going on in its narrative so by the time
it ends it's a little difficult to
unpack let's break down the ending of
annihilation from a galaxy far away the
film's primary question is what is the
shimmer the film's opening shots show
some sort of interstellar object
careening through Earth's atmosphere and
crashing into a lighthouse which becomes
the prime destination for the research
and military expeditions into area X
which is what the land surrounding the
shimmer comes to be known as the shimmer
as it turns out is some sort of alien
force it's either a thinking living
breathing thing or a kind of celestial
cancer replicating itself unconsciously
either way its whole essence is
ultimately tied to an alien entity that
we see take on humanoid form in the
film's closing moments through the prism
annihilation second question is what
does the shimmer do determining this is
the primary goal of Lina's expedition
until her husband Cain came back nobody
who entered the shimmer ever returned
and he seems to be sick no longer fully
in control of himself and clearly in
pain with Kane out of commission the
area X crews still can't say for sure
what happens in the shimmer even after
throwing team after team into its
clutches until Lina and her crew journey
in despite the way our protagonists are
picked off one by one the shimmer isn't
an explicitly destructive force the land
inside is an a ravaged wasteland but a
lush exotic forest filled with surreal
flora and animals that only resemble
those native to earth the scientists
discovered that everything exposed to
the shimmer is in a constant accelerated
state of mutation and that mutation
isn't confined to singular DNA sets
instead the DNA is collectively jumbled
up animals become mixed with the plants
organic and inorganic materials combined
connecting all of nature in a very
literal very impossible way do you think
it's a crossroad we can't cross bridge
between different space
the end times it's established early on
in the film that the shimmer is
spreading as a scientist journey deeper
into its confines we see that Area X's
original headquarters has been
completely overtaken by the shimmer its
thread is made abundantly clear by
Jennifer Jason Leigh z-- dr. Ventress if
it goes unchecked the shimmer will
consume the world based on what we see
it'd be a gorgeous apocalypse but it's
still an apocalypse while beautiful the
shimmer is littered with corpses and
mutations and filled with an
overwhelming sense of dread humans in
the shimmer encounter violent ends like
Anya's death and the jaws of a mutant
bear or they give themselves over to it
in humans this DNA remix in leads to
madness making them disoriented agitated
and spaced out the film never makes a
statement on whether the shimmers
effects are a good or bad thing it
simply presents them as an inevitability
face to face toward the film's climax
Lina encounters dr. Ventress who has
finally made it to the lighthouse
however Ventress has become a part of
the alien force that created the shimmer
and she soon transcends her human form
and becomes a sort of fractal prism
herself after this prism absorbs a drop
of Lena's blood it takes on a humanoid
form in this moment Lena
effectively meets the shimmer while it
initially seems malicious the shimmer
never actually sets out to harm Lena
instead it just mirrors her movements
it's an important moment that embodies
the goals of the shimmer it seeks
understanding and integration it
assimilates to its environment the mass
mutations and prism effect are the
result smashing the mirror as their
confrontation with the shimmer creature
comes to a head the creature now in a
humanoid form and morphing into Lena is
given a grenade by the real Lena she
places it in the shimmers hands pulls
the pin and runs as the grenade explodes
the shimmer creature catches fire the
light house burns destroying the
entirety of the shimmer with it it
cements the idea that the shimmer is one
large collective beam and also allows
Lena the opportunity to escape and make
her way back to area X self-destruct
sequence
annihilation is a movie about
destruction the idea that deep in our
genetic coding there's a primal urge to
destroy ourselves in the world around us
the shimmer serves as an embodiment of
that inevitable urge it destroys what we
have and turns it into something new for
better or worse that penchant for
self-destruction is explored intensely
through our protagonists Lena is a woman
who ruins her marriage with an affair
indirectly influencing her husband to go
on what is potentially a one-way mission
Alma is a recovering addict Josie bears
the scars of self-harm Ventress is dying
of a cancer mutating their insides which
informs her fascination with the shimmer
these characters all have a subconscious
wish to end their lives so their
journeys ever deeper into the shimmer
have an air of inevitability
even though Lena survives she only does
so by destroying a doppelganger of
herself metaphorically wiping away her
old identity and emerging as something
new quarantine qat following her return
from the shimmer Lena is forced to take
part in an extensive debriefing about
her journey while under a strict
quarantine is it the real Lena or a
double after her time inside the shimmer
the truth is somewhere in between after
her questioning Lena is finally reunited
with Kaine who's no longer dying from
the shimmers effects and even seems
somewhat lucid what Lena knows and
others don't is that it cannot possibly
be him new me new
the most ambiguous moment of the film
takes place in its closing moments Lima
has known since encountering her
husband's remains at the light house
that whatever's back in the area X
facility isn't him rather something new
her being reunited with this Kane isn't
quite the moment those around her
believe it is she knows the truth and
needs to tie up one last loose end
reunited with Kane's doppelganger Lena
asks him if it's really her husband and
his answer is not encouraging I don't
think so are you Lena Kane is something
new as well as the last remaining
fragment of the shimmer whether he's
fully aware of it or not
in the film's haunting finale the two
embraces both of their irises fluctuate
and changed color
signaling the continuing mutation and
evolution caused by the shimmer it now
resides in Lena and Kane who will live
on to change the world even further it
might not happen soon but the primal
coding that sends us toward
self-destruction remains as an
inevitability that nobody and nothing
will ever fully escape thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all these cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]